So, it turns out that the relationship
between how much I would work and
how much I would make can be described
with what's called a linear equation or
the equation of a line.
In this example,
we would use maybe y to represent
the amount of money I'm going to make.
And it turns out that this
was equal to 10 times x,
where x is the number
of hours I would work.
So even though these are just letters,
x and
y, they represent hours worked and
money made.
But this is getting a little cluttered.
Let's use a chart to
organize our thinking.
And I'm going to organize my thinking
with what's called a t-chart,
which looks something like this.
And remember my equation y = 10x,
where y represents the money I make, and
x represents the number of hours worked.
Well, we've already seen that
if I work 5 hours, I make $50.
And if I work 10 hours, I make $100.
And I could keep filling this chart out.
The interesting thing to note though is
that each row has two numbers in it and
for the purposes of graphing I like to
write these numbers as an ordered pair
with the x value first and
then they y value.
Notice they're separated by a comma and
they have parenthesis around them.
So if 5, 50 is the ordered pair
version of this information.
How would you write this row of
information as an ordered pair?
I've given you the comma and you just
have to enter in the two numbers.